hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we are not actually hunting on a old
game we're on a new game today called
apex legends the new battle royale game
from respawn entertainment it is a mix
of titanfall blackout overwatch is
people and saying but to me it's a
titanfall battle royale game and I'm
loving it so much so today I'm gonna be
giving you some 10 beginner tips to help
you get another win or your first win or
just to help you slowly build up so that
you can eventually get better at the
game so let's get started so first one
is communication in Apex you have you
always have to play as a group of three
you can opt not to but most of the time
you're going to be put in a game of
randoms and usually people in video
games and playing at randoms that's not
really a good idea so don't expect the
carry every game always try to be with
your teammates and synergize with them
if you see a teammate that needs heavy
ammo and you have an extra drop of it
and then ping them if someone needs
level 2 armor and they have level 1 hit
him with the ping you can also paying if
you can defend an area if you want to
advance forward if there's an enemy
there's a zipline you can ping anything
and your teammate will see it and your
guy will call it out pinging is the most
useful thing to do in a team because
it's instead of communicating in game
chat you can use this so that everyone
knows what your plan is and what you
want to do number 2 is wall climbing now
this isn't actually taught in the
tutorial but instead of jumping at a
wall if you tap the jump button to move
forward your character will actually
climb up the wall and you can reach them
places you may not know you could have
gotten up to so it's very it's a very
useful tip that you can be utilizing
maybe get atop a roof or some type of
rock it'll be very useful
number three is knowing at your
character each character in apex legends
is very unique so in other abilities and
use them accordingly if you need to hold
down a position and you're planning
Gibraltar place down that shield and
give some protection to the teammate got
an enemy you can't find it use the
trackers vision pulse and detect them
immediately TLDR basically know your
character use the abilities according to
the situation at hand and don't try to
overuse them since they are on a
cool-down but try to use them as much as
you can because it will definitely help
during a fight number four is grab a
buddy this is a pretty quick tip but
giving pulling with a buddy gives you
actually more XP I believe it's some
type of survival XP so you can actually
use that to which obviously of course
the higher you level up the more
materials you get the more loot you use
so grab a friend or two and you'll be
getting lots more loot to show off in
game number five is grabbing weapons
that fit your
character in the individual place
thought of yourself and the character
you're playing this is based off the
previous tip since tracker is all about
tracking the enemy the pulse actually
doesn't go too far so you do want to be
up close and personal so picking an AR
shotgunner SMG is very good to synergize
with his abilities and of course this
goes for every other character in the
game now I obviously haven't played
every single character I haven't I'm not
a master at all of them but knowing the
character that you're playing
knowing the ability and understanding
how their abilities work and then find a
weapons to help with those abilities and
synergize can really help you get and
win those teamfights number six is
paying attention to the map and the
death stashes on the side of the screen
looking at the map is a legend telling
you what some of the things are within
the map the green dots are the respawn
beacons which I'll get into a little bit
later the pulsing blue circle is an
incoming Supply Drop which has a chance
of dropping gold and purple items which
will help very well throughout the end
of the game is that a blue circle is an
area with a high chance of good gear
this is you usually want to drop there
in the beginning if you want to stock up
immediately but some players might also
have the same ideas you should
definitely watch out you may get into a
fight very quickly the destinations are
also very helpful - not only do they
give you the person that killed you
their loot but the color also represents
the highest rarity item that they have
in their stash so if there's a downed
teammate next to you and there's also a
gray stash don't go for the stash go for
the teammate the great loot probably
isn't that worth it anyway
what if there's two stashes in front of
you one gold one purple definitely check
out the gold one because it could be a
weapon it could be an attachment that
you don't use but you never know it
doesn't hurt to check and the next one
is the spawn beacons and the balloons so
there is going to be like I said there's
going to be spawn beacons throughout the
entire map when a teammate dies you can
pick up their spawn beacon before it
goes away you can go to a spawn beacon
in them within a couple seconds they'll
respawn back into your squad now they
will not have any of the weapons they
died with sadly but it's better to them
having there than not having them at all
so because they can find other weapons
and then it's just an extra man that
could be in your on your team loons are
also pretty useful once if you go to
little balloon and then slide all the
way up to the top they'll basically
really because if you're parachuting
back from the beginning of the match you
can go very far distances so if you want
to if you need to get to the circle or
if you just want to get on with a
situation you're in
swing up to the top of a balloon and
then Coast off to a different area
number eight is do not be afraid to use
your Ultimates The Ultimates are pretty
crazy if good in this game and they
recharge somewhat quickly and can easily
change the fight if you're in one so use
them and I
wouldn't recommend using them every
single fight but if there's a need to
use one definitely go for it they're
very useful number nine is speed
momentum now this is obviously talked
about in the tutorial but thanks to
bunny hopping while riding and double
jumping not being present in Apex but
wasn't titanfall - your only option is
to slide sliding down hills and even on
sliding on flat ground can gain you
faster movement than spit then running
so definitely try to use that to get
across the map quicker whether you're
chasing the zone or you're trying to get
away from a fight definitely try to use
as much as momentum as you possibly can
so you can - and dip away from all the
opponents fire and then my last tip and
you'll probably solve this all coming
just have fun with the game it's a free
to play game with no horrible
microtransactions at least as of yet I'm
not entirely sure but their plans is
hopefully they don't do that please
respond don't be adding
microtransactions nobody wants that so
far the only microtransactions that I'm
obviously cool with are cosmetic so
don't beat yourself up over the game
it's free you're not wasting money on a
$60 game since you paid nothing to play
this so if you died in second place like
I have three times today don't worry
about it you'll come back and get a win
it next time
maybe your friends are playing just as
well teach them how to play show them
the tips and whatnot and hopefully
everyone can get better at the game and
you have a lot more fun playing because
it's more of a chill and relaxed
environment and this isn't some type of
game that you paid $60 for and you have
to sweat your ass off so don't stress
too much about it any guys gonna be my
10 tips for apex legends let me know
what you guys thought of the tips in the
comments below if I happen to miss a tip
that you thought was very important that
I happen to miss Devin definitely let me
know in the comments below I'll be sure
to give it a heart so that everyone can
be caught up to date with what tips that
they should use for apex legend so they
could get better at the game the thing
guys for coming out to the video I
appreciate you like the V if you do
enjoy subscriber for new I haven't
really but this is the first video of
apex legends I've actually posted if you
guys want me to do more I'll gladly do
more then love in the game for the past
day or so so I'm definitely be playing
this a lot more as it continues to get
more legends and stuff like that and
more loot but yes subscriber for new
guys and peace out enjoy the rest of the
game in deuces
[Music]